were you distracted by his accent no not
really look like Tom Hardy I get that a
lot
you know I think it's a compliment you
couldn't be bigger he's 140 naturally
well we're not we're not you know say
you're the same size as Dan Hardy
I don't know you're probably get all the
time you're probably Tom Hardy sighs who
would you say I'm a little bigger taller
I'm definitely stronger hold on
you went mmm don't you know don't do
that go ahead no go hmm I say that cuz I
did a movie with him now with Tom what
with Tom Hardy but you did yeah with
which one Tom Hardy which movie a movie
called warrior low a hell of an actor
though oh yeah is that the height that's
the fighter one yes plays the brothers
yes yeah I saw it
I've no desire so warrior you'd live it
I don't like fight movie there's nothing
to it fighting you love it oh it's a
story brothers brothers have to fight
phenomenal movie yeah you were great in
that you played what is accounted feel
like you're being okay so I'm gonna ask
you I played you like yes he was Jack
see that Bryan Callen you played
basically the Joe Rogan okay the Joe
Rogan role but you did I did you beat
yeah so that was he's a lot where I keep
doing it quietly and you're being in
doing a Socratic thing you're you're
asking questions but I think you know
the answer so thank you for saying that
I Socrates I didn't I didn't give you a
I was a handsome son of a [ __ ] take a
look at me let's zoom in on that picture
I'm listen you need to fill out the 401k
no this is gonna be a lot of money and
you want to put it away
no and no that's not use it when you're
60 cause it'll grow those weren't the
[ __ ] lines your shoot was tailored
huh well yes askew actually it's a
tighter suit demand does that ankle
right cuz now are you it looks like
you're you're in a fight in that scene
well my natural I have a martial
presence my natural tilt muscle at my
chin now so if you swing at me you're
gonna catch forehead Moe and joel
edgerton Zinn that too huh yeah I'm not
gonna catch forehead he's a monster
and a good writer and a director yeah
don't both guys are those
two minds of acting yeah and and then
you got you in there and that's just
great for you trying to track no I you
what you're saying that I'm doing it I
don't know you do realize it dominant I
really now go shoot do you have anything
to do with talk soup coming back did
they call you like hey is this cool do
all the soup my friend the Scott's here
this was talk soup though and this is
the soup right well no mine was thus
okay because that when that talk soup
was only about talk shows way back when
before you were born when you were
getting out of graduate school I don't
like it okay well you don't
hey this is their oh hey yeah that was
me yeah
alright different there are a lot of
different hair yeah are going on isn't
there a thing though that it can they
can become painful when it's happening
it's like awful hurts so bad but then
they just gets harder it calcifies but
that but can it can a break for a while
you can't like there's been fighters
where the it gets really hard and they
do know like scuffle and they like rip
off or some that's not good okay and if
we that you so yours is from wrestling
my grappling right he was in the UFC
heavyweight for 10 years 10 years
yeah right is that fair no 10 years six
was in the you see I think six but for
bad each other that your face is that
you don't there no thanks man no big
scars we've got his nose broke so what's
happen a store to to you Brian
what's your excuse for you know I had my
nose broken a couple times like and yeah
front a cuando from wet to cuando cuando
Karate Kung Fu I mean whatever it is my
box you box their boxes this morning uh
who did you fight okay so I just today
was hitting just mitts so again it Amit
nope
I said mitts see and now you're doing
that thing about him nice okay are you
all right see what I keep doing and I
apologize okay but hey I don't know why
I'm killing it what do you guys what do
you do for your work how much were you
when you play when you
five I was like 240 something 242 that's
when I love for watching that stuff
because I'm not no never never
Brian when you broke 150 what did you
think you know all right I wasn't
blessed with let me see that I might say
that - I'm very much there was another
restaurant in that Felix Oh company lamp
and company yes Felix Felix is down on
Abbot Kinney
yes Felix's Oh have you Sousa Rogan is
obsessed now because I took him barracks
yeah and oh I played him in a movie he
played his accountant right Joel Joel
again that's a question that I think you
know the answer to now I play oh my
sounds Holly about this yeah I played
Bryan Callen alright so yeah nope you're
not though you see you're not I know I
came in here I have been there once they
beware off fabric in is it weird that
where it's where the old Joe used to be
it's gonna open up to say like I'm too
reckless it just seems like it you can't
really plan but I think what it might be
like a friend if you were to start
working out for the first time in your
life and to wean I can't say I'm gonna
be on the olympic IFBB think Joel know
you've done that again now Ida train I
train you haven't seen with my shirt off
yeah and and and so be careful because
I'll show you maybe but don't drop the
same you weren't two shirts yes three
you know chilly I keep my mid body warm
he still wears a wife beater like he's
1907 it makes me feel a little more
muscular I get that yeah that makes a
lot of sense highlights my shoulders
maybe might have been engineered there
is evidence that did they see the clouds
for the rain in the last two weeks you
just spit out damn a choice
Joel you're trying to alpha me right
size 13 alright [ __ ] man he's run big
Duffy yeah you can't do that with your
feet cuz you're clearly trying to one-up
me right now I'm on right here I want to
hear the howl it was all playing well
hey
see there's evidence I didn't say that
I'm just saying people the DNA I may
know some people all right scientists
who are noticing that it does look
different
can you give us the name of that
scientists could have escaped from the
Wuhan it could have escaped from a Wuhan
lab why did you back up Wuhan twice to
say it even as if you knew how it's
pronounced because I speak different
languages like like the ones that
depending on where I've been I am pretty
poor for language do they speak and move
on they speak what do they speak yeah
Chinese what Janice why you say it so
quietly because you're saying it a
slightly different way it seems like to
hide the way you're changing hey Jimmy
is it racist to call because I call it
Mandarin from my dad he's like that no
Mandarin is a language Mandarin is the
main life Mandarin is the main form of
Chinese spoken in the man now why didn't
you visit Mandarin in a certain way that
you've been saying the others because
Mary I'm marrying him I see but you how
would you say these are spoken in Hong
Kong so they're different a lot of
different dialects yeah but Mandarin for
the most part cuz the Yangtze and the
Yellow River and kept people speaking
the same Yangtze and the Yellow River
yes it's not the same river there's two
rivers the month is called Jack's yellow
in Chinese and the other ones just
called the yellow yeah because it
depends on the S here are you're talking
so the Yellow River bring it up in China
Qin bring us it up bring up the [ __ ]
yeah bring up the racist River believe a
sister hey don't do you think Trump's
can get reelected if he pulls pulls us
out I think it's a very interesting time
and I think yes uh-huh
right yeah oh okay
I guess women that's the principle River
and then the basin and the Yangtze River
oh you have you have there are they
different rivers run through okay I
apologize
I was right and I knew I was you you're
so small in these chairs it sounds like
I sometimes go you can't know this thing
that small he's a young person okay and
but then you're older and no see and so
I'm really sorry you've been you gave me
a crutch you apologize but then you
insulted me twice so win Oh just raise
yeah just you so the Yangtze and the
yellow yes so Mandarin is the main
language spoken mmm I almost remember
one time I was patty Jenkins we were in
New York City and and I was a young
comic and it was packed
David tempation this is 19 cents I was
like where's everything lit with candles
everything was lit with candles and as
chaplain the smalls ox was going on war
all right now and there were no vaccines
but in Higgins you must give these great
men and women the power to enforce this
task if necessary surprisingly it's Ana
politics my friend when the true
seriousness of this is on the story oh
he could he could be the president
yeah I love him what if like he's no no
was his vice presidents looking every
bid you ride be he might beat 185 I was
good boy yeah so did chunk yeah that's
it he's 185 he might be there he gets
pretty big yeah weighs about 50 pounds
listen I feel terrible its we're in the
middle of a pandemic and you came on the
podcast now you've been battering
without emotion I don't I don't I don't
know you do so you see it do I feel
terrible no you don't see you feel you
don't have a seat
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]